[Musique]
je suis valérie bazin malgras 51 ans je
suis député de l'aube mais par ailleurs
conseillère municipale à 3 et
conseillère communautaire à trois
champagnes métropole alors moi je suis
auboise je suis né dans l'aube je les
fais mes études dans l'aube j'ai
travaillé dans l'aube
alors mon intérêt pour la politique est
venu parce que j'ai été pendant
longtemps présidente d'une grande
association de commerçants magasins d
usine qui était la plus grande d'europe
c'est comme ça que j'ai connu françois
baroin je le voyais parfois dans des
réunions puisque en tant que présidente
d'un grand centre commercial
j'étais amené à voir monsieur le maire
la chose politique
la collectivité les autres m'ont
passionné et quand françois baroin m'a
approché pour me demander si je
souhaitais entrée au conseil municipal
je me suis dit que c'était une super
opportunité de s'occuper de sa ville
tout simplement c'est vrai que la
politique et moi c'était pas une grande
histoire d'amour puisque on est venu me
chercher
donc ça déjà c'est quelque chose
d'important ça veut dire que des
personnes très compétentes ont vu en moi
quelqu'un qui pouvait y arriver
donc merci à ces personnes là qui sont
françois baroin par exemple et nicolas
villeroy de galhau dans ma vie
professionnelle
la politique ça passionne tout le monde
il n'y a rien de facile
les élections législatives en ce qui me
concerne il a fallu vous imaginez monter
dans le tgv et ne pas pied sur le frein
pendant un mois quoi donc ça a été
redoutable mon premier mandat
c'était en 2014 à la ville de troyes
donc élu sur une liste chef c'est
françois c'est pas la même chose
là c'est moi sur la fiche c'est que moi
et tout le monde veut la place parce que
personne ne sait ce que ça mais tout le
monde veut la place et hyper jalouse et
y parents viennent faire la politique à
au quotidien ça me plaît beaucoup parce
que c'est quoi faire des propositions
donner son avis construire des lois
importantes intéressante pour notre
société pour nous tous je trouve que
c'est éminemment important il faut le
faire avec son coeur avec ses
convictions et c'est ce que j'essaye de
faire au quotidien avoir une préférence
c'est pas simple parce que dans un
mandat municipal
on s'occupe de sa ville on s'occupe de
la politique du bout de la rue les gens
qui nous connaissent qu'ils nous voient
être député de la même façon on
travaille pour sa ville et pour pour le
coin de la rue mais c'est quand même au
niveau national donc moi je vais puiser
toute mon énergie et toute ma force
auprès des gens de ma circonscription
pour ensuite porter leur voix à paris et
faire en sorte d'amener des propositions
à ce qu'on me soumets je ne peux pas
vous dire les deux sont tellement
passionnant et c'est bien dommage
justement qu avec le non cumul des
mandats les parlementaires ne puissent
fut justement être dans l'exécutif local
une des causes qui me tient énormément à
coeur c'est la ruralité
ça fait deux ans que je suis rapporteur
pour avis sur le budget de la culture
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le
patrimoine culturel des petites communes
parce que j'estime que l'état ne donne
pas suffisamment de moyens aux
propriétaires privés ou aux
collectivités pour rénover leurs
bâtiments
mais après j'irai que quand on est
parlementaire tous les sujets sont
tellement passionnant et pour presque
tous je vais faire des propositions on
s'interroge on propose un mandat de
député ça dure cinq ans moi je suis pas
exclusif sur un truc social ça me touche
beaucoup
voilà un peu les sujets qui m'anime mais
y en a tellement d'autres
les modèles qui ont formé mon engagement
c'est très sentimental ce que je vais
vous dire mon mari déjà à la base mon
mari médecin généraliste qui m'a fait
confiance depuis 30 ans ensuite dans ma
vie professionnelle il ya eu nicolas
villeroy de galop qui m'a fait confiance
très jeune pour me confier la
responsabilité d'un magasin où des bus
en sites de 3,4 puis après
la responsabilité des magasins d usine
sur sur la france pour la société
villeroy et boch et ensuite il ya eu
françois baroin évidemment grâce à
françois baehr moi je suis ici
aujourd'hui chez les républicains
c'est vraiment mon modèle en politique
j'adore sa simplicité son honnêteté son
authenticité
donc ce sont ces trois hommes en fait
dans ma vie qui m'ont permis de me
construire politiquement et puis
construire la femme le caractère que je
suis alors le département de l'aube
c'est un département assez rural avec
une prédominance du monde agricole et
viticole ma ville de troyes c'est la
plus belle ville de france a bien
entendu on a un patrimoine historique
magnifique en plus de dix ans on a fait
venir plus de douze ou treize mille
étudiants
donc c'est une ville qui est de plus en
plus regardées à je suis troyenne
auboise je ne trouve que des qualités à
mon territoire ouais bien sûr chez nous
c'est l'andouillette et le champagne et
chaource hop
donc on mange très bien la gastronomie
c'est fondamental dans le département
j'adore cuisiner
je suis très triste en ce moment avec le
confinement je peux recevoir personne
mais j'aime beaucoup cuisiner invité ma
famille mes amis
or j'aime beaucoup ce que je faisais et
je pense que si je n'avais pas été
député j'aurais racheter une société
pour avoir ma propre société avoir des
salariés faire prospérer une une boîte
ça aurait vraiment été quelque chose qui
m'aurait plu c'est peut-être pas perdu
je le ferai peut-être un jour alors le
conseil que je donnerais quand on veut
s'engager en politique il faut être
simple humble parler c'est bien mais
travailler c'est beaucoup mieux de
l'efficacité du courage du boulot et
comme ça on progresse et on y arrive
mais le message que j'ai envie de passer
à tout le monde à tous les français ceux
de l'aube les autres nos militants c'est
que la démocratie est importante
allez voter s'exprimer c'est important
il ya des grands rendez-vous qui vont
arriver il faut pas les oublier
je trouve que c'est fondamental de
pouvoir donner son avis on voit ce qui
se passe partout dans le monde le
populisme gagne de plus en plus et
chacun peut participer à la démocratie
on peut dire oui mais non les politiques
ne font rien machin oui d'accord mais on
peut tous s'engagent et voilà donc
engagez vous
où aller voter ça c'est des messages que
j'ai envie de faire passer
[Musique]